hey Brian I'm trip adler I'm the
co-founder and CEO of strip and I'm
going to answer your question about what
keeps me motivated um so P smoke be
motivated is it's building a great
product that makes people happy and
ultimately makes the world better place
I know it sounds a little bit cheesy but
I really think that it makes that makes
you much happier know that what I'm
building is really going to improve the
world i mean script is a product that
allows authors and content creators of
all kind of all kinds to express
themselves and share ideas and it allows
people to find information and content
and reach interesting things and I think
that's really important and while we are
building a business and the goal is to
maximize revenue I think it's important
to realize that the the real reason why
you're doing that is to ultimately help
people and to to build something that
leaves the world a better place so
thanks a lot